[Music]
did you go out of your head the day
facebook crap the bed
time stood still for several hours
yesterday as facebook instagram and
whatsapp were all down and for a few
terrifying hours people around the world
suddenly found themselves being
productive
this just says 60 minutes aired a
segment in which a whistleblower claimed
the company covered up evidence that its
platform was spreading hate
misinformation talk about a coincidence
that's like me calling in sick after a
night hot tubbing with geraldo
oh it's food poisoning
no it's geraldo poisoning
ooh that got an ew
as it turns out facebook's own engineers
were to blame they admitted as much in a
blog post with a bunch of high-tech
words like configuration changes on the
backbone routers
translation some dolt hit the wrong
button
they leaned against a switch and it
effectively removed facebook from the
internet it's hilarious it is hilarious
what button did they push to make it all
go away and can they do it again
permanently
it's a good
yes
i'll take the applause i'm shallow it's
a good lesson for all of us it's why we
never let our interns get too close to
the controls
steve do not press that button what this
button yeah
[Music]
that was amazing oh my god we're going
to be in so much trouble do not press
that again why would i press it again
five passengers set sail that day for a
three hour tour
oh that was awesome do not press it a
third time we got lucky the first two
times do not do it again i got it
[Applause]
you know uh tyrus it's a little known
fact there is a button in this building
that can change the stations while we're
on tv did you know that a remote yeah
it's a universal remote wow and it
changes everything man i need to go back
if you missed something yes yes yes did
you miss me when facebook went down we
couldn't look we couldn't share photos
okay first of all i don't have a
facebook so who's the guy i've been like
no i don't know because i don't
i sent private personal photos to you
you never once bothered why i never
commented oh you thought i was keeping
you you said i looked hot in that yeah
well it wasn't me guffield yeah i don't
i don't have facebook uh i like playing
outside but
i hope for those who and there was a few
people that i saw were getting pretty
upset and i was like six hours you you
that you need to look in the mirror real
hard if you couldn't look at a picture
of somebody's fake life yeah for six
hours but more importantly that this
whole the leaking thing and seeing that
facebook is just like our government
where they try to play everybody against
each other and and profit from it
this could have been a good time for
parents to really think about it
to we need to make sure that
our kids aren't on social media there's
no they don't need it just like you
wouldn't give your kid a beer and a pack
of cigarettes right don't give your kids
social media because of the the
long-term effects can be actually worse
than cigarettes if you're looking at
some of the stuff that's going on and
that's the same effect on the brain
right the brain chemistry is affected
and we need to challenge facebook why
are not why is it only celebrities that
are verified why is not everybody
verified why
you have to have an i know democrats are
going to cry you should have to have a
driver's license or an identification
card to have a social media account so
people know who you are you can be held
accountable and we can stop all the fake
not like what the guy asked for
the fake the fake i have a instagram
account for both of my animals
wow this does well i have nothing else
to say
[Laughter]
i give up
you're uh you're an expert in this sort
of thing susan you've talked about this
on fox business where she is and you and
aside from your course language um you
have a lot to say about this what is
going on well a lot of people came up to
me saying it couldn't be coincidence
right right after 60 minutes
whistleblower a testimony on tuesday and
then all of a sudden everything blows up
because of routine maintenance yeah i
would say yes it's kind of hard to
believe for a company that's worth a
trillion dollars that has what 60 of the
world's connected internet users on
their platforms and one button brings
the whole thing down yes they leaned
against it i hope that's true i don't
have any evidence for this but that's
never stopped me from making a definite
claim about something
but i didn't use global backbone
capacity yeah data servers that would
have put you to sleep oh yeah you can
just put those string those words
together susan doesn't mean a damn thing
to me but
you sound great doing it that'll tell
you that much cat you were probably did
you get the shakes by the way it seems
kind of weird that people think that
it's a big deal facebook is kind of dead
right
yeah i mean you're more into tick-tock
i know i was leaving
for a couple it's on tick tock for a
couple weeks i i probably do spend uh
too much time on social media but i i
don't agree with people saying that
being addicted to social media is the
same as being addicted to heroin which
i've heard a lot of recently if you do
mean that both should be you know free
of heroin use and opiate use and social
media should be free of government
restrictions i do but anyone saying the
addictions are the same has clearly
never met a heroin addict yes like true
i dated one very briefly
i literally did uh whatever it was long
distance i realized he relapsed and it
was over pretty quickly when i realized
that he definitely did uh long story
short he died owing me thousands of
dollars uh i don't think that's gonna
happen to little susie who's on snapchat
too much don't worry the irs not really
a comparable situation i don't know i've
gotten a lot of money out of that tyrus
guy
[Laughter]
it's not me gutsville
he paid he paid for a lot of those
photos corey
photos that i give away for free
anyway
would the world be a better place
without facebook absolutely i mean look
here's the bottom line so we know for a
fact that the taliban as they continue
to clear out all afghanistan what do
they utilize as their actual
communication method whatsapp not to
mention the fact that facebook which i'm
surprised hasn't been investigated
further and i found out earlier is
responsible for over half
of the active recruitment of sex
trafficking oh wow so that's all for
facebook i mean
granted i feel bad for the guy who's
like i've lost all my friends i have to
go actually talk to people now i haven't
had facebook since i don't know high
school but the whole point is is that i
think that the world is better off
without a lot of the social media people
have to actually go out and engage with
one another you can't have sexual
predators and others who are basically
preying upon the way they do you with
your photos yes and so you know and not
to mention the fact that they're
actually there's terrorist organizations
who can be verified for example as a
congressional candidate i can't be
verified on twitter but don't worry
about it the spokesperson for the
taliban has a as a twitter approved
verified account and you have a better
beard than him so true
so true
uh
there's a joke in there i feel so
flattered right now yeah it wasn't me
gut feeling all right all right i gotta
go they're gonna waving me on thank god
because i say something offensive hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else